les quiero mostrar algo
no
y nada más
me
y más
dios
aquí tenemos a martina una niña de 5
años aprendiendo a leer de hecho muchos
de nosotros aprendimos a leer igual que
martín a
formamos las sílabas
pero ninguna de las palabras tendría
sentido si hay algo que le ha tocado el
radiador
las palabras con cosas que conocen
perdón es una de las siete que como
nosotros
vienen unos y otros pero nosotros
mandamos nos comunicamos con palabras
y la capacidad de comprender el lenguaje
es la representación de la información y
nosotros los humanos la interpretamos a
través de cadenas de textos que se basan
en tres pilares fundamentales
la sintaxis la semántica y la pragmática
la sintaxis es el orden de las palabras
se fundamenta en la gramática
combinaciones de palabras para crear una
unidad mayor la oración la semántica el
significado de una palabra la forma el
significado de una oración y la
pragmática que busca entender como el
contexto influye en la interpretación
del significado
muchos científicos de datos a lo largo
de los años han estudiado cómo crear
máquinas que entiendan el lenguaje
humano de hecho en el año de 1950 alan
turing uno de los grandes científicos
del siglo 20 conocido como el padre de
la computación y que muchos han de
conocer por una película que muestra su
trabajo donde crea una máquina para
decodificar los mensajes nazis en la
segunda guerra mundial presenta un
artículo donde considera una pregunta
las máquinas pueden pensar
se imaginan en el año 1950 ya alguien
cuestionándose si las máquinas pueden
pensar
y
e
el icbc y tenemos 22 naciones donde hay
un doctor
si el interlocutor no lo conoce
si la valoración no quiere
bastante
y
como duda de él como muda
quedan todos transformamos está en
coloración
esta técnica es una actualización
nada
el lector y xinzo los combinamos todos
estos valores y vamos a tener un espacio
de seguridad
en matemáticas podrán encontrar las y
los directores ya que hacer es porque es
un total similitud de palabras podemos
comprar las relaciones goles relaciones
pero sí desveló entre la modelo cumple
matemáticos probabilísticos
que los ayude de patrones de la
comunicación de todos nosotros
el ladrón
él
ah
dado
decide necesario rápidamente desgracia
nacional
y uno se pregunta pero como no puedo
hacerlo
siguió el abecedario me lo sé de memoria
porque tenemos patrones de
comportamiento todos los seres humanos
tenemos patrones
una de estas técnicas que últimamente se
escucha mucho se llama aprendizaje
máquina machine dern estas técnicas
buscan cómo dotar a las máquinas de
capacidad de aprendizaje entendido éste
como la generalización del conocimiento
a partir de experiencias
algo importante aquí es generalización
es decir que si yo aprendo algo que está
en un círculo no solamente aprenderme
eso sino que cuando vea un dato nuevo
poder aprender a generalizar a sacar
conclusiones a partir de lo que aprendí
pero con circunstancias nuevas no les
suena parecido es lo mismo que hacemos
los humanos los humanos vemos una
situación nueva pero actuamos según
otras circunstancias quizás que no sea
parecidas pero que hemos experimentado y
si una técnica de aprendizaje máquina le
ha dado gran valor al procesamiento del
lenguaje natural natural son las redes
neuronales como su nombre lo dice se
parece a nuestro cerebro
tenemos neuronas que se conectan unas
con otras
todo funciona
y
los dejamos de información creamos una
nueva población
y asintomática a otra corona y así
sucesivamente hasta de la obtener una
conclusión
pero por qué todo esto
es decir
ah
la escuela
todas las informaciones con cosas que
llama sociedad hay más de eso
educacional
un niño rodrigo pérez
como por el contrario queremos hablar de
niños
pero
la invitación
como en el contexto cultural
como mi vida
si yo
todo a uno cercano
como sea el banco para de realizar
bueno
para un humano para todos nosotros muy
fácil porque porque tomamos en cuenta el
contexto la situación pero las máquinas
no
si yo una máquina le digo le preguntó
que le diga que ve en esta imagen no va
a decir un vaso agua o quizás una mesa
si yo se lo pregunto a un amigo me va a
decir yo veo un detector dinosaurios
de hecho si vamos a un buscador y
ponemos detector dinosaurio vamos a
salir a estas imágenes porque porque la
película jurassic park cuando se
acercaba el tiranosaurio apareció un
vaso con agua las máquinas no llegan a
entender esto todavía
pero los humanos y los chistes son
cadenas de palabras pero estas palabras
no tienen sentido literal
de hecho hay un chiste entre
programadores donde se envía una máquina
al supermercado y le dice quiero que me
traigas un cartón de leche y si hay
huevos trae dos que creen que pasó
trabajo 12 cartones de leche
son cosas que las máquinas todavía
tienen como retos deben de entender el
contexto si yo le digo a alguien estoy
aburrido lo que quiero dar entender es
entretener
un reto más importante en la
inteligencia artificial en el
procesamiento del lenguaje natural es el
viaje humano el sexto todos aquí tenemos
un días todos aquí percibimos el mundo
de una forma distinta al resto
y tenemos días buenos y días malos si
este racismo existe máquina
y en esa petición
de edad indicada
detrás de nosotros
y nosotros tenemos
uno de los lados
señor secretario
y logramos la sal
voldemort
le dan la manera de ir el ingeniero de
filosos
cómo
por qué
y es importante
y tenemos que creemos nosotros estemos
reflejando latente
al golear
traductores
análisis de la percepción negativa
clasificación
natural
las personas debemos de lyon
imaginando
las normas ya puede escribirnos
[Música]
haciéndolo
conocido verdad
la manga a la perfección
existe el mundo
y
e inmediación
d
y de igual forma nos falta menos
pero
se activa
también como queríamos
y qué hizo la queremos abrirla
buscar
[Aplausos]
[Música]